Let’s say you have this cuboid shaped box
placed on the table!
Try pushing it a little.
You will require some force to push it forward.
Now place this same box on top of cylindrical
shaped pencils and push it.
What do you notice?
You will notice that the force required by
you to push it to the same point as before
will be lesser!!
Why is that?
Do the pencils reduce the friction between
the box and the table?
Absolutely!
But it’s not about the pencils; it’s about
the SHAPE of the pencils.
They are cylindrical…
Assume you are travelling to another city
and you are carrying luggage weighing around
25 kilograms.
If you are unable to carry the bag, the only
option you have is to drag it on the floor!
But you will still require a lot of effort
to drag your bag.
But what if your luggage had wheels under it?
Won’t it be FAR easier to carry it around?
Yes it will be easier!
But the question is why?
Why is it easier to roll a box over cylindrical
pencils relative to pushing it on a flat surface?
Why is it easier to carry the bag around when
it has rollers under it?
Hold on to this thought!
I’ll come back to it.
Before we discuss the above situations,
we need to understand what SLIDING FRICTION is.
The concept is simple!
It is the frictional force which opposes the
relative sliding motion between the two surfaces
in contact ! What does this mean in simple words!
It simply means that if an object is in motion
on a surface, the frictional force that is
offered by the surface is called the SLIDING FRICTION.
The key words here are SLIDING MOTION!
The two surfaces have to be in relative motion
with each other!
In our example, when a box is moving on the
table, we say that the box is in relative
motion with the table.
The resistive force applied by the table when
the box is moving is called sliding friction!
Remember, the objects have to be in relative motion!
Because there’s movement involved, this
force is also called KINETIC FRICTION .
Now consider the example of the luggage in
which we don’t have the wheels under it.
When we move the luggage, what will the resistive
force applied by the ground be called?
Yes, sliding friction!
But what happens when we attach circular WHEELS
at the bottom of the luggage?
Yes, the friction gets reduced to a great extent.
This type of friction which arises when an
object is rolled on a surface is called ROLLING
FRICTION.
It is a force associated with rotational movement!
Now can you tell me by pure intuition about
which force will be lesser?
Sliding friction or rolling friction?
[pause]
Yes, rolling friction is usually lesser than
the one associated with sliding friction!
And that’s why attaching wheels at the bottom
makes it easier to move the object around!
And similarly, moving the box on top of the
cylindrical pencils is also easier!
Can you think of more examples where the concept
of rolling friction is used to reduce the
friction?
Yes, tyres of your car!
When the car is in motion, the ground applies
a force of resistance which is nothing but
rolling friction on the tyres!
Do you remember seeing ball bearings?
They are spherical metal balls used in many
mechanical structures which have moving parts.
They’re generally made of stainless steel,
brass or ceramic!
They reduce friction to a great extent which
in turn reduces the wear and tear of machine
parts!
So we got the concept of Sliding and Rolling friction!
There’s another interesting type of friction
we need to know about!
Will the force of friction come into play
only when the two things are in relative motion?
Not necessarily!
To know which kind of friction I’m talking
about, watch our next video!